new york governor andrew cuomo is
criticizing law enforcement officials
who refuse to
enforce the state's latest covet 19
restrictions
including the 10-person cap on private
gatherings ahead of thanksgiving watch
this
well i don't believe in that law and
therefore i won't enforce it
that is
frankly frightening to me
as an individual frightening to
democracy
it's arrogant and it violates your
constitutional duty
my next guest says guess what he is
actually not going to enforce the
governor's limits on social gatherings
fulton county sheriff richard giardino
joins me now sheriff great to see you
today thank you for being with me
first of all what goes through your mind
when you hear the governor say what he
just said
that you don't have the right to to not
just not follow the restrictions
it disturbs me because i think he
doesn't understand the distinction
between
a law which we learned when we were
young that a
legislature passes a bill it goes to a
governor president and they either sign
it
or veto it and an executive order
legislature in new york abdicated the
role by giving full authority to the
governor
these are executive orders that's why he
can issue an executive order to a bar
or restaurant or a gym because they all
have licenses
under the state liquor authority or the
health department
and so therefore he's got control under
the
authority of his departments and that
they can limit hours they can limit mass
they can limit distancing
and seats in the restaurant and they can
find them but an executive order aimed
at an individual in their home
everyone just gets that sense without
even me having to cite the law that
something's wrong with that
now interesting on your lead in in
oregon it was
six people at your home in new york it's
ten yeah so does that mean
that the covet is more dangerous in
oregon
and less dangerous in new york it means
they're picking arbitrary numbers so
that's one reason it would not survive
constitutional muster
as a former superior court judge and a
former district attorney
it's incumbent on myself and the
governor who both took an oath of office
to uphold the constitution
and i'll stand by the constitution every
day over an executive order
uh steuben county sheriff another area
of new york
james allard said in a statement
officers will not be peeking
in your window or attempting to enter
your property to count the number of
persons at your table on thanksgiving
you mention those numbers i bring that
up
governor cuomo said he's not asking
anybody to do that but said if they
receive complaints or happen upon large
groups inside for the holidays
they should break up the parties how do
you happen upon my living room that's on
the back side of my house
good question good question one of the
suggestions was well if there's
10 cars or a neighbor complains we still
need
a search warrant your consent we can't
just go in
into your home and the problem is it was
ill phrased because it gave people the
impression that the governor was telling
them
and that there's some sanction involved
people respond better when they're asked
to comply
in our state the numbers are very low
we're 1.3
percent county and people have to
remember that our
goal is to keep people alive and reduce
this but it's got to be done in a
constitutional manner
and what we know is 99 percent plus of
people who contract it
get over in a few weeks unfortunately
those at high risk
die and dr falchi's been telling us for
eight months
the numbers are gonna rise in the fall
and when they're gonna rise they're
gonna get bad
so you know somebody said to me well if
people get covered in your county you're
gonna blood on your hands
it's up to the individual to decide by
now they all know what the precaution
advice is
stay away mask and i think people are
smart enough
not to put their elderly and at risk
people in that environment in fact
most people who've talked to me support
me supporting the constitution
but they also say that they're changing
their thanksgiving this year
they're limiting it they're just family
they may just pass over it so people are
doing that without an
order to do so well
not only are they hearing what you're
saying but they know that you know what
you're talking about
and your background as a former judge
and attorney really helps
you make the case let's see if the
governor is paying attention
uh sheriff chardino fulton county new
york thank you great to see you today
thank you thank you harris good seeing
you have a nice weekend and have a
limited to 10
thanksgiving day i'm gonna
adhere my personal responsibility and do
what you say sheriff thank you
very much don't tell me how many you're
having or i'll have to send a swat team
and i don't want to do
that harris or where my living room is
apparently
okay happy thanksgiving thank you